i have a loaded question oh good do you
think uh she is the one do i think she's
the one
what the [ __ ] is going on i
like to party jesus honey
this is unwaxed
we're going shopping with sophia and
sistine stallone we just become best
friends
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwaxed podcast
with your favorite sister sophia
stallone
and then my
sidekick tina is so cute are you ready
she's being sarcastic but you know
and we have a final winner hold on oh my
god
you're so annoying you know what we'll
save mine for the next one um yes as
sophia said welcome back to another
episode
we are a little bit delusional today if
you can't already tell running on about
two hours of sleep but that's not only
it i feel like we haven't slept
consistently at all this week it's been
two hours of sleep for the past three
nights you know i wish that there could
be a camera on me all night i'm not
gonna do that because that sounds really
suspicious but
apparently i sleep talk a lot and i've
been asleep crying
crying i've been sleep crazy i've never
actually heard of that i know and i wake
up covered in
wet tears
obviously tears are wet uh see i'm
delusional today
but i've been sleep crying and i don't
know what's going on with me i i did
have one
too many shots yesterday so are you sure
you're not just sweating out all the
alcohol that was just out of my eyes
maybe out of every hole everything was
just probably i went to
the rams playoff game and they're going
to the super bowl
wait can we just say how mom said that
she thought she knew who won before the
game even ended because she accidentally
actually wasn't even her fault my dad at
three o'clock said that's when the game
started there in florida he accidentally
bought a rerun of an old game and so my
mom i'm facetiming her while the game is
on and she goes i already know who wins
she was acting like it was some big
secret i was way crazy i'm like no you
don't know who who's winning because
it's still live no one minute i'm at the
game in real time and she goes to steam
but i already know who won i'm like that
is impossible no so gabby knows because
she was with me and i was like either
you're in a parallel universe or time
just sped up before she's our illuminati
yeah or something but she was so set and
she got into specifics how the 49ers
would win
and then suddenly i'm flipping the
camera i'm like it says final the rams
won and
yes it happened to me my dad made her
watch for two hours an old football game
between the 49ers and ryan's and the
49ers had happened to go over time at
like the same kind of numbers this just
goes to further my point of
why haven't parents figured out how to
work a tv remote yet and why don't they
understand technology i think it's a
refusal to learn i do too
it's so infuriating it is because they
assume that their kids will just do it
and help them but then they realize once
they're alone
it's a lot harder than you think unless
you don't put in the effort i mean it's
mind-boggling sometimes sly will mess up
on a caption and i said dad you spelled
this wrong and somehow he manages to
spell it worse yeah well dad also has
like the biggest thumbs i don't know if
you can really press the keys
all too well that's a call out well he
does he has big fingers he has big
fingers um
aside from my tiredness and hangover
i walked into our lovely podcast studio
today and noticed a different
arrangement one that's real a bouquet of
flowers
not plastic they're real flowers with a
card with my name in it and that's not
something i see often and i thought you
know what
should i open the card on the show
it's funny because this morning she's
all like i'm tired this and that and i'm
giggling on the side she thought i was
making fun of her or something so i got
a little side eye from her but i'm
giggling sophia was giggling so much i
yelled at her to stop giggling yeah and
i was just excited that she was getting
flowers but i couldn't see anything
so sophia why don't you fetch me the
card there i can't exactly lift my arms
i can't lift my arms in the shirt look
at me okay
your queen
here we go
reading
the card
i think he's going to love the fact that
you're
reading the card hello
oh
that's really sweet can you read it out
loud
do you think he would let me
yeah i can read it
okay
sistine
i love you so much comma
i'm so proud of you
blank
love
sofia it's okay no
wait that's so sweet
how does that make you feel that i got
flowers and you didn't
you
know it's okay because you know it's
been three years and i'm
still in the same position yes you know
what though i this is something that
i've never i've never gotten treated
this kind before no you don't get a lot
of flowers how about ever ever yeah wow
that's really sweet you know i think
flowers are super underrated
contrary to what sly says about flowers
ignore them you know don't drop in a
hundred dollars
it's not a bowl of salad slime they're
beautiful you know what it is flowers on
random occasions that's what i think is
nice i think when it's a holiday yeah
generic flowers you want to do that
everyone does that but i think on a
random day if you know your significant
other is feeling down and then vice
versa for girls to guys if your
boyfriend is feeling off just like get
him i don't know what do guys play with
legos like
look get them legos
oh my god do you remember we used to
build bionicles
um yes and i by the way do you guys
remember bionicles when i had a hinge
for two seconds one of the questions was
something you wouldn't know about me is
that i used to build bionicles what do
you think my number one question that
everyone liked and answered wait that
was that one that was how you filled in
that answer yes i wrote bionicles and
every guy was like how do you know about
this like do you remember i used to
build them for dad and there was like 12
on his wall sophia we got so good good
at building them that we wouldn't even
need to read the instructions no no no
no
no
exactly what every nook cranny screw was
for which part you said that so that was
your answer for that hinge question
something you should know about me is i
used to build bionicles mine was
something you should know about me is
that i once swallowed a bee
not on purpose yes i actually did get a
lot of responses remember that it didn't
made her swell and i remember her ex was
laughing about it but i don't think he
knew how bad it was it stung my uvula
yeah my uvula i was so shocked it
happened i wasn't even crying i was
laughing and everyone around me was like
ew that's so gross i look in the mirror
stick my tongue out and i see the
stinger right on it in the center of my
uvula and i said i gotta take it out
with tweezers
but you're never supposed to take a bee
sting out with tweezers because
apparently it pushes the poison in but i
couldn't fit two credit cards in my
mouth and i'm gonna cycle pull it out so
relax you're being so so i get in there
like a boss
with my tweezers
pull it out
it was disgusting
i ended up getting strep throat for ten
days was on a steroid and uh how does
that even and i couldn't eat or swallow
anything so i just sipped on tequila not
complaining what was the tequila purpose
because i just kept saying it's gonna
sterilize
pretty
loopholes
um you went to the rams game you said
yes i did that you went tailgating you
would be so proud of me first of all
this is my first tailgate ever i am so
jealous that you went like i was on
sensory overload i'm walking in
everyone's got their setup people got
the grill there was tri-tip i just
learned what tri-tip was i thought it
was a seven-layer bean dip
that's its own that's another
whole that's that's it in itself there
were people performing
songs and there were people rapping and
there were people playing guitars i mean
it was a fairly it was literally like
the county fair i said this is insane
there was nothing
more painful honestly than throwing back
warm tequila shots at 12 in the
afternoon that was pretty painful but i
wasn't gonna not do it i had to commit
everyone else was doing it but i was
really proud of myself to kill a shot
was for the rams that's true
during the game this is the first
football game
that i actually sat and watched the
entire play but i did start to finish
you didn't go get the sliders that you
usually go although i did do that and i
came back i came back um but what do you
feel how do you feel about it now that
you actually watch the whole thing you
guys i understand why people like
football now this is crazy i know i love
seeing progression i know i mean you
know it would be kind of fun if it was
like the puppy bowl like that way more
to me thanksgiving i love the
the kitty did you know there was a
hamster bowl
shut up there was a hamster bowl there
was also were they all in hamster balls
no they were going crazy that's actually
hilarious yeah oh my god sophia do you
remember when we had hamsters this is
the funniest story oh my dad didn't take
us to school one day per usual and he
goes we're going to petco yeah we said
okay and he goes all right don't tell
your mom i didn't take you to school but
we're gonna go to petco and he bought us
hamsters and it was really weird they
gave us the hamsters in a brown lunch
bag yeah like it was very suspicious
like it was like yeah school meat it was
weird exactly so the hamsters
unfortunately didn't have a long life it
was really tragic we thought we were
doing the best taking care of them yours
killed mine
you're my hamster did not murder you're
a hamster you murdered my hamster
because your hamster had a cough
penelope did not murder your hamster
what was mine like mine was a little
black one yeah what was it i don't know
definitely like a zorro or something
stupid but i thought it was zorro
actually i think it was it was something
like that my mom actually ended up
telling us because we were devastated
and she wanted to protect our little
fragile heart she said that she brought
it to a hamster hospital
and we believed her oh yeah we did and
that our cancer had a severe cough
oh wait wait is that why i got the i got
the flu
is that where i got the cough from is
that because i thought that the cough
was what was that real or was that
because mom no our hamsters didn't have
a cough
and a runny nose every time i thought
our hamster literally had a cough all
right enough about hamsters let's talk
about who we have on the podcast because
i love that introduction before guy i
have to say we just finished this
conversation with this guy and
it was not what i was planning on at all
it didn't go the direction i was hoping
but it turned out way better yeah i
couldn't i expected i'm so pleasantly
just surprised about how
well spoken he is and wise and smart
smart yeah yeah and really driven i
think you guys are going to learn a lot
from him and you're going to take some
tidbits and he's hilarious along the way
so yeah you guys are going to enjoy this
episode so stay tuned
i'm extremely excited about our guest
today because when i reached out to him
i honestly didn't think he would respond
and now he is sitting to my left today
we have on actor co-host of the wildly
popular podcast called impulsive if you
haven't heard of it you're probably
living under a rock we have content
creator and stand-up comedian i mean
this guy is taking the internet by storm
we have the iconic george janko on on
wax studios
and you guys actually have like an
audience
i love it i don't know actually one day
we should actually get a live studio
audience that's the goal i think you
need like three more people like but
it's going to be a fire hazard at this
point
it's a hazard you know we wanted to
thank you we have a little gift for you
well thank you so much would you want me
to open this here on the camera or like
whatever you want whatever your heart
desires you can check it like a little
bit i'll put it in the middle
and then when i feel like interrupting
you while you're talking i'll open it up
randomly amazing you know i'm kind of
shocked because
you live how long have you lived in l.a
i lived here for
seven or eight years okay so i can't
believe that this is actually the first
time that we're meeting yeah
it's so weird i always talk about this
uh there's so many times i meet people
and i'm like i know these people but i
don't know these people right yeah like
exactly i feel like we all run in the
same crowd but then we just never
talk to each other i know and you know
it's also weird sometimes when i see
people on the internet a lot i think
that i actually know them personally
yeah so i sometimes like right now i
feel like we're already friends because
i've seen a lot of your content i mean i
saw you on vine back in the day
i mean i see i watch you on the podcast
and you're so talented and funny and i
definitely want to just
dive right into where it started because
i sometimes think you know comedy isn't
something that
you can learn it's something you kind of
it just pours out of you naturally yeah
yeah yeah did you grow up always funny
like what kind of kid were you i was
always the kid that talked oh i got my
first time i ever got suspended for like
a week was because the teacher was like
i just got to the butt of a joke
and i was about to throw the zinger yeah
and she says one more word that comes
out of your mouth you're suspended uh-oh
and i was like suspension
or i don't finish my joke and i
literally was like i can't it's a zinger
yeah and so like i let it rip the class
was just dying of laughing i just
started packing wait do you remember do
you remember what the joke was no idea i
just remember my mom actually brought
that up to me she reminded me like two
years ago we were like gathered for like
something that like was special for me
and everybody's telling stories and she
told that story and i just forgot about
it obviously during the time my mom was
like pissed yeah but she's sitting there
with a smile on her face and it kind of
warmed my heart like all those [ __ ]
moments i put my face right right
they're like sitting there and cheering
and uh my mom goes i'll never forget i
knew this kid was gonna do something
with whatever entertainment it was but
i stand there and i just got done
grounding him i was like in the second
grade yeah i wasn't i was i was like i
started young a little menace yeah and
uh
she goes why didn't you wait until the
end of the class and i was like mom it's
all about timing
timing he knew she literally roll she
she said i couldn't she had to turn her
face because she was like who says that
yeah
no it's pretty jean so you obviously had
a natural inclination did you always
want to go into comedy no so uh my mom
randomly were in hollywood you know
hollywood blockbuster yeah yeah yeah so
we were a huge huge movie uh like goers
like oh i love that like when you dm me
i go yo rocky's daughter
my dad's like no way that's so cool it's
like iraq that's awesome
and uh uh so uh
so wait i'm so sorry i kind of like lost
my train by the way fyi this whole week
i was off got blasted out of my mind
really nice i this is why i wanted to
create art so i called my parents i go
guys is that why i'm gonna be smoking
weed right for the next like four days
to see what i created but i kind of just
hopped off of it so my brain is like i
don't know if you guys do you guys smoke
weed or not no no like maybe once a year
i feel like a repercussion after smoking
way too much after four days and
stopping immediately yeah i saw i just
started smoking weed this year or like
no last year okay uh because i have
really bad insomnia like i can't sleep
there'll be three days straight i know a
lot of people that have been doing that
lately more so it's been helping but i
don't know do you get dependent on it
now after a while 100 percent yeah and
i'm i'm a severe like
seve i know that i'm i have like those
attic traits
uh and i kind of i know this sounds
crazy but hear me out a lot of my
cousins on both sides of my family have
lost their lives to like some type of
addiction wow so i grew up and that's
why you will never see me do any
sponsors for like gambling companies or
alcohol companies yeah i tend i don't
promote or do anything that i
kind of feel like god would be upset
with me doing right um
and uh
marijuana was only introduced in my life
because the doctor's like listen i could
give you these meds that's gonna help
you sleep but i just i think your brain
just doesn't know how to shut off right
so if you could just smoke to calm down
and then you could just fall asleep
all day and then i just smoke at night
okay but i was off so i was like i want
to go to the beach higher i want to do
all right right yeah yeah so i just
tried it out and did it so you're like
i'm just going to take it away from the
bedroom i want to go into other
recreational activities yes yeah yeah
and by the way i know this sounds really
stupid i'm 29 years old every decision i
make i ask my parents first i know that
sounds really weird no i do that
i like that no you give me [ __ ] for
calling mom sometimes asking if my
outfit looks like look i was sitting on
my mom's lap in public the other day i
don't care okay no that's a little wow
on my dad's lap oh no i said mom i'm not
the sly that would be super weird in
public but you said that you were
smoking weed to create art uh yeah this
week i did it because i always had a
rule of thumb like don't do it for art
right because i didn't want to fall down
that rabbit hole of like losing my life
too
so the reason i said that is because i
realized at a very young age bringing me
back to the hollywood blockbuster oh
okay my mom rented me a michael michael
jackson tape okay cool and i she played
it one time and we have this on camera
so it's really cool so all these things
i i get to talk about one day god
willing i can make like a little doc and
show people that process but
she showed me michael jackson he did the
moonwalk
and a week from that day was the talent
show the reason she did it she's like oh
maybe you should just get up there and
dance like michael jackson walk did you
do it so i looked at him doing the
moonwalk and i go i could do that and
she goes there's no way and on camera i
watched him do it twice and then i just
i started doing it and then you got it i
just did it and then she was like what
the [ __ ] is going on she's like that
doesn't make sense so you're a born
performer i learned his whole routine
you study it you study you're like very
observational obviously
probably a lot of comedy and they know
comedic timing then the i mean now you
know the moonwalk well i just knew what
i could do and i didn't know i already
so i got made fun of so much i had to
move school so many times so i think i
kind of i started out at the slate of
like really you're not like people like
i don't care what people think yeah like
i truly didn't care because yeah the
open opinion is everybody hated me so
like i was kind of like well i start
here
like this you know i can't go down
anywhere you can't go any worse
about that because um sophie and i also
had to move schools every year every two
years she was severely bullied to the
point where the school actually had to
recommend that she would that's what
happened to me so i would love to know
senior year of high school all the way
up until high school yeah we were in my
freshman year so you had a bad ending
out of bad scenarios no no it was
ongoing oh ongoing so i like immediately
when the school asked me to leave i was
like i'm out of here so i can just
change and make it better i had the
weirdest things happen to me though why
is it like i wasn't like the kind of kid
that would go and mess with people yeah
neither was i i wasn't intentionally
asking for people to no very introvert
shy no so i wasn't that that that's what
my dad's advice is like hey buddy just
shut the [ __ ] up
maybe people won't like come after you
yeah but so i i that was the day that i
realized i wanted to be entertainer i
looked at the michael jackson thing i
mastered it so much so right i performed
it at the uh the school talent show a
week later and people went [ __ ] nuts
whoa and that's awesome uh
arizona's uh
what was it the you know the pageant
show miss arizona yeah they asked me to
perform there to do the
michael jackson thing so then i did that
wait how old were you when i was in that
was in the third grade wow three or four
confidence wow oh no i had
dumb confidence like it was like it's
like blind arrogant confidence like i
don't care what anybody do you think you
still have that level of confidence that
is an adult yes i actually was talking
to my girlfriend about this so i'm very
spiritual and i uh i i have this i have
a theory that i'm working out right now
yeah through just
process of like
watching something reflecting on it
moving on doing something else i like to
try new things okay
i'm on this frequency right now that i
believe that every single person
that was born was born by a creator
mine i believe in jesus so i believe in
god
uh
my higher power built me with a purpose
but he doesn't want to interfere with my
choices
because he gave me free will so how can
i align with his purpose and my goals
well if he created me that means i'm in
line with what he wants me to do so that
little thing that you have in your heart
with anybody has in their heart like i
want to be this or i want to do this
the moment they start getting scared of
chasing their dreams is when the devil
is like i'm trying to steal you from
your purpose right and once you stop
believing in what god can do and
really start believing in what you can't
do you lost the battle yeah yes i've
been in la for
eight years or eight to seven years
years and years go by of me trying to
conquer the room right
trying to be the best in the room trying
to figure out trying to outsmart trying
to build try to braille try building
yeah and i kept running into this
problem and i kept asking god i go i
keep doing this doing this i keep doing
this and god's like it's hilarious
you're not talking about what i need you
yeah
so about like
two years ago around i stopped asking
god like yo what i need
yeah i know there's something in my
heart that i need to do i know it has to
do with entertaining right so i just
started every day asking what he wanted
me to do right and every day i started
noticing like opportunities that kind of
like it was annoying it was like the
longer route
but once i kind of got there i i finally
got into a place in my life where
i could have all of my dreams
and his purpose and then this is what
gets rid of my depression anxiety
is because it's a yin and yang of me
trying to battle with my flesh and my
spirit right but my flesh wants the easy
route i mean look at us now look at
social media look how we live exactly
everybody wants that now down now
instantaneous yeah and when people look
at me and they're like you you believe
in jesus you do this bible they're like
why do you do this like what makes it
like what makes you right because when
you kind of get to the level not in a
boasting or cocky way when you get to my
level a lot of people they become
arrogant they think it's all about oh
yeah
i realized when i read the bible all the
rules weren't for me to like yo there's
a king on a mountain and i'm like i'm
gonna obey you i'm gonna do everything i
found out through this that these helped
me out with my life
so i just got into this rhythm of like
okay there is a way for me to balance my
spirit out and my flesh out it's the
harder way right but like i'm in a
relationship right now
uh that's very healthy yeah
but if i didn't know realistically and
and that sounds really cheesy but if i
didn't know my relationship with god
yeah right
i wouldn't know how hard it is to love a
god like a guy it's so annoying yeah and
we never open up that conversation and
be like bro i'm so [ __ ] annoyed to
this guy he's so annoying like
talk to me like figure this [ __ ] out
like we need to do something yeah and i
i got this this all of these childhood
thoughts out of my head so now when i
stand in front of my girlfriend dude i'm
at a mature level where i could think
hey there's times where i look in the
mirror and i don't even like who i am so
how the [ __ ] am i going to love who i'm
with 24 7. right oh my god we say that
all right
when i'm taking these biblical like
lessons and implementing them in my
relationship with my friends uh my
girlfriend my career i'm telling you
dude i just i found the sauce of like
being able to deal with the most dumbest
[ __ ] yeah and
not that i had anger issues but like i
grew up from the bullying [ __ ] i did
mixed martial arts yeah and the only way
i could get my body to [ __ ] not is
getting in the ring and either getting
knocked out or not it's only the way to
get you out of your own head yes right
and it's just i was building it and
driving it off of anger okay and that
came coming down so i figured out that
all these other avenues that help they
come with a price because it's the
shortcut yeah yeah so now i grew like
the the the patient's understanding so
i'll be having conversations with people
and they're saying the most ridiculous
[ __ ] all my friends like yo [ __ ] this
person that i could tell that this
person is damaged right they're hurting
i've been doing the most reckless i was
at a party once at my friend's house and
this girl was doing blow
okay just straight on the table and all
my friends were like yeah like
everybody's having fun they're doing all
this [ __ ] and in my heart i was like god
this poor girl bro like why is she doing
this that's exactly how we look at
people no i'm not looking down but we
always look at them like we feel sorry
like though i just questioned like what
brought you here because you're hurting
you're trying to use the substance to
get you out of something right you were
saying that you've figured out and you
aligned your purpose god and all that
stuff is that because do you think that
some people just don't know what their
purpose is because i feel like the
hardest part about figuring out what you
need to do what will get rid of your
depression anxiety is what will get you
to wake up in the morning yeah what is
driving you yeah yeah and i'll think of
not actually most people have a really
hard time figuring that out and you were
just lucky and that you saw instantly at
the age of you every road is different
right yeah so
for example if you're asking me okay
will you give us advice to someone but
what if somebody doesn't have her yeah
so like someone is that girl let's say
she doesn't have a purpose or she
doesn't have a
anything to tell her you know maybe this
is not the right path for me because i
don't have something else that's keeping
me away from that yeah i guess it kind
of falls in the same route because
remember i started doing the music thing
i i had my own vision right right i had
my own plan and i was telling god what
my plan was right and what it's hard for
us
and i'm speaking only for the side of
the spiritual right i can't speak for
somebody who doesn't believe in a higher
power it's not fair for them you know
right right but if i'm speaking for that
side of the of the people uh
the thought behind it is it's it's you
need to humble yourself yeah you need to
know that you're the human and he's the
god right so like you have to kind of
get to a place where you're like all
right just because i don't know where
i'm going yeah there's four or five
different bible verses in the bible
where he talks to blind people
like let me give an example there's a
guy who came up to jesus and he was uh
he was blind and he goes i know if i
just touch you that i could see
and and i i found this really funny
jesus spits into the dirt and he makes
mud i just wanted to pause and that that
was hilarious yeah
he spits like come on you're jesus you
can wink at the guy like how he did and
you could have sleep but god was having
i don't know like a sense of humor he's
like i'm gonna spit into this dirt i'm
gonna make it muddy i'm gonna put in
this guy's eyes and he saw so the guy he
goes go to the river and wash your face
right yeah and the guy wasn't like homie
i'm blind you want to walk me to the
river yeah he didn't he was so excited
that he knows what he has to do then he
knew how to get to the to the river so
my my thought process is
maybe you haven't been able to see yet
because it's not your time yet right so
when i needed to be a stand-up this is
eight years into the game
20 years into people told me that i
should do it and i had no idea and god
never put it in my heart to love it yet
god ever put it in my my head to be like
yo this is your thing yeah yeah the
first time i touched took stage was this
year and i was like oh my god i've never
loved anything more so trying to run
around you said that you
knew exactly when the right time was to
approach stand-up comedy yeah noah
actually was brought to me and it fell
in my lap and i just don't like turning
down opportunities so i like so how was
it brought to you explain that so i was
on impulsive so i was on impulsive was
accidental yeah how did i even i got on
and i did this where i talked about like
just spiritual things like how i i'm
very open and honest i'm really not you
are a very vulnerable person which is
amazing and i like it too because i've
never seen anyone that sort of is in our
realm of content creating
outspoken about something like this and
i think it's really cool that you do
that and i'm sure you get a lot of
positive feedback i do and then there's
a lot of people that like yo chill
brands don't like this like movie things
they don't like they don't want to get
too on the spiritual side but okay again
it has to do with greed right yeah god
already gave me so when i grew up my to
be in a movie to be on a show
to to do live performances these are all
dreams i've ever had now i've
accomplished every single one of them at
what point would god look at me selfish
if i had all these things to get people
out of depression
but i was like no because i want more
money and more opportunity i'm going to
keep the things that benefited me yeah
in a happy direction yeah but just
because people are like
don't do that you'll get less money you
get less people to [ __ ] with you and and
respectfully like
[ __ ] them like i don't care i don't care
there's a lot of crazy people out here
right yeah the world's going crazy and
if i'm crazy because i'm trying to get
people out of depression and anxiety
just because i'm speaking from my point
of view never pushing them on it i'm
just saying hey this works for me
do it and if they're like yo i don't
want dude like i don't care like i've
already right right right like at what
point do i gotta stop
questioning what my god could do yeah
this is all the opportunity this is all
the passion this is all the careers
every single one of them by the way and
logan said this on a podcast he goes how
life works for you is weird people will
step in bless me with a crazy
opportunity just walk away wow stand up
was joe coy he was uh one of my favorite
comedians i dm'd him to get him on the
podcast he was my first guest to ever
invite him oh wow and he just we just
like that just happens
yeah for yourself because you knew that
you're like this is gonna well i just
saw the opportunity to have yeah timing
was right you know logan's show is huge
right he's my first guest i was like
i'll i'll see what happens
off stage uh i was just making him laugh
and he's like yo
you should do this yeah yeah you started
mentoring me and wow what dude like i've
been in rooms with comedians that i
would i had to walk out he has it on
camera because we're docking this whole
journey there's moments where i
literally have to leave dinner yeah to
pretend i have a phone call and i'll be
crying in the bathroom because i'm just
in disbelief
that these people are at my house having
dinner with my mom and dad and me and
i'm sitting across the table and they're
turning to my mom and they're like did
you know your son did this this on stage
and this girl's been in every movie my
mom's ever watched and watching my mom
cry from like teachers sitting me at a
table telling her that i wasn't gonna
amount to anything until like her
favorite oh my god that is like what a
that's a moment yeah so then at what
point do like these people are like yo
stop preaching god's name and then i'm
sitting here receiving all of his
blessings and like why would i stop
don't share it why would i stop yeah
exactly so i i figured out my lane i'm
gonna be the guy that you're like like i
don't care
do you wanna say i don't care i have i
have a girlfriend right
my family my check yeah my career right
now i had it and if it goes away because
i had the balls to talk about god then
sick i'll meet him in heaven and be like
bro remember what i had a career and
you're like it's all god i got that i'm
at the key i'm at the gate so we're good
i still have the girlfriend the family
so
hopefully that's why she's like babe it
was real i was really at the career how
was the girlfriend how was it great has
it been long or short two and a half
years wow that's a long time first
girlfriend that was like a legit one
yeah an la relationship i would assume
is quite hard to keep yeah i don't know
why this is a dating app thing or is it
a wholesome introduction so wholesome
introduction
one of my close friends was like yo i
met this girl that i i don't know why
but i feel like she's the one for you
and i was like yeah
so i actually we were just friends and
all of my friends were uh trying to hook
up with her because i was like nah i'm
okay like yeah you guys later on that's
why you got her you're the only one
going nah i got her because i was like
damn none of you guys could pick this up
i was like ah
i swear that's like i told you i got it
i literally was like all right my turn
uh my turn
and uh i went in and i just accidentally
found love it was uh did you know
immediately that this was gonna be
different the first date was about the
first date that was like this is
different i was talking to two different
girls at the time okay but i was open
about it yeah and i said oh you know
like i'm just having fun yeah uh
and i i know it sounds really weird but
even in my [ __ ] stage of my life i
didn't like i don't like
sleeping around too much yeah just feel
like it grosses me out no i got that i
like to have like this sounds more
[ __ ] up so bear with me i like to have
like a rotation of girls that i know are
like really really good girls that are
not like [ __ ] around and [ __ ] like i
know okay so i'm still a [ __ ] bag you're
like i just didn't want to catch her
you're like a relationship [ __ ] he's
keeping it no he's keeping it on wax
it's fine
you can be honest here oh yeah i'm
always honest yeah so uh i was i was on
a date and we like before even the
appetizers came the way she was staring
at me and she was talking i kind of like
forgot the [ __ ] she was saying but she
was just talking and i pictured her as
an old woman oh what i'm saying an old
woman no and me as an old man and i had
a picture of us at a park together oh no
as an older couple and i like that
popped up in your head and i literally
looked at it i go i think i'm gonna
[ __ ] marry you one day you said that
on the first date i said i think i'm
gonna marry you one day and she's like
oh that's pretty straightforward for the
first date
and uh and by the way it wasn't even
she's like the same
way i saw it wait that was your supposed
first date it wasn't even a date so sh
again she was rejecting everybody so
then i said hey i got this these dinner
plans at masters today and actually oh
whatever i
accidentally that
i go and also you should bring like the
nicest restaurant
sweatpants
hold on i said how about this we'll go
to dinner bring a backpack with you uh
that has sweatpants and a hoodie i go
and if dinner goes well and you feel
comfortable get into something
comfortable let's go mini golfing and
then watch a movie
and uh yeah that's a pretty good date
yeah was that happening that was
actually pretty genius yeah we actually
were talking about it we actually got in
a really bad fight
uh
for the first time like in a long time
we really ever get in fights right and
we got a really really bad fight and
what i love and again sounds corny we
get really mad and i'm [ __ ] dude i'm
ridiculous when i get mad oh right
because i'm the type of dude that won't
pop off but if i pop off i'm calm
but like if we're going to get an
argument you're done i'll disassemble
you like i know how to talk no you just
i'll use your words against you
i remember everything you say so if you
[ __ ] slip up one thing i go what is
it
sustain always goes back to like three
years ago she has i don't know where
that time said this thing oh i remember
word for i remember
i forget everything yeah so i lose every
argument yeah and she's more calm she's
like the most patient woman
so i'm just like blah blah blah blah and
then we just both sat there and uh
we're literally like all right what are
we doing yeah and so we're like how
about this let's cool off and talk later
so we cooled off we came back we prayed
before we talked to each other
cheesy
so we prayed about it and then randomly
we 30 minutes of deep conversation still
wasn't getting anywhere oh uh the you
know those photos of the day yeah yes
two years of our memories because in my
photos i have moments with belle
and it had like a ten minute thing of
all and we were just sobbing
watching it and then we just like you
know [ __ ] it's not even it's not worth
it just moved on that was a sign that
the way that that had happened that day
yeah really though pride is literally if
anybody's listening to this podcast i'm
telling you right now if you know unless
you pride
it's [ __ ] dead
just the one person yeah just the one
person that's listening to my mom i love
that though and i feel like your
relationship must be a lot of fun
because you're a funny guy we're weird
but we like the weird [ __ ]
that's what it is it's when you can feel
so comfortable with someone that you're
like i can be as stupid we are saying
the dogs
you see my girl like this and she's
looks like she's been crying for 30
minutes it's not it's just she's not
did
romance
she's
the same thing for you or is she are you
the one that just does the phone she
never will ever far in front of you
she's like by the way no i agree with
that
i'm sorry i can't do it i'm woke bro
fart in front of me no you know what i i
can't do that look the way that you're
describing a relationship we just had
our parents on the episode before you
and they've been together what almost 30
years yeah 30 years and in the industry
too by the way yeah industry and yeah
they're good as gold and i asked them i
said why do you guys think you've lasted
so long and my mom said because he makes
me laugh and i just think that humor in
a relationship and they don't take each
other seriously
each other all the time they don't give
a [ __ ] they'll just say the dumbest
things to each other they don't they
have no thick skin i have a buddy named
greg lindsey and he was my roommate when
i first moved to l.a yeah the caliber of
women you get here and any other place
on this earth is is different yeah like
really like the ugliest guy or the
ugliest girl in that ralph's is the
hottest person in your town 100. so when
i came out here i i hit on a girl in
front of him and he looked at me he goes
buddy he goes never do that again and i
was like because i was kind of like oh
you remind me of this girl you friends
though we're friends she's so pretty and
he's like what the [ __ ] are you doing is
that your move no you're wrong
okay and he gave me the best advice ever
he goes listen don't try too hard ever
yeah yeah smell that [ __ ] from a mile
away that's true he goes just be the
party make them laugh don't ask them for
a thing he goes once you make a girl
laugh to a certain point she could be
with her dad her boyfriend her friends
but she'll remember that she feels a lot
happier with you
then she'll want to just keep being with
you but also don't give her a reason to
keep calling you like oh buddy and [ __ ]
like yeah yeah yeah yeah have your own
like that's true you gotta go like
you're right yeah
what does a girl have to do though that
makes a guy get better attention on her
that she's like maybe not too
overbearing or maybe she just pulls away
enough oh you gotta know your worth i
think that's the one thing that's my
girl like she is a [ __ ] bombshell
confident the most talented person she
was on dave you guys ever watched dave
yeah yeah she was like the girl that uh
he had that scene with at in the studio
that deep scene of him like trying to
move on oh yeah so that was her scene so
i i watch her audition and dude this
girl's f she's going to be huge she
kills it but it's not her body it's not
her brain right right i know it sounds
crazy but i think the sexiest thing on a
person is just know your worth yeah if
you're not invested in you why would i
invest in you yeah completely you know
what i'm saying no i enjoy it we all
want what we can't have so if there's a
part of you that's like this is part of
my life that you'll never have yeah this
is my business this is my relationship
this is mine so it's like there's always
that attraction do you think it's
because she has her own life and her own
passions careers dreams and completely
different mindsets and they get
intertwined like we're together 24 7 out
of the day it's better but she has her
own things are you guys co-dependent or
not really or very individual we're
actually more partnerships we talk about
everything now so it but it grew into
that like when we first started dating i
didn't post on social media like that
not because i was like a scumbag well i
don't we don't i don't know anything
about a relationship yeah you don't want
to have the whole world intervening well
honestly our reasoning i wish it was
like the whole world intervening we have
some serious stalkers yeah and they just
harass these dudes and we feel so bad so
that we just avoid it so really yeah i
mean i'm not dating anyone but i
remember my ex and i posted on family
they still hurt still today it's so sad
but yeah i agree but i also think when
you're in the entertainment industry and
you're always on social media especially
with us we're doing the podcast we have
our instagram there's other things
coming up even for you
the one thing that you can keep grounded
and wholesome is really something that's
important which is your relationship you
have to you have to
okay so like logan
is one of the most famous [ __ ] people
on this planet bro we go to like italy
and people shut down cities like this
kid is at a different breed like of a
level
even him me mike all the people around
us were so grounded right and no one's
scared of popping somebody off they're
like kind of going down the right yeah
they're like though our friend group is
very tight and they very much keep each
other in check yeah you are who you hang
out with yeah so like if you have some
[ __ ] people around you i don't say get
rid of them i hate when people cut them
off but that sounds like that kind of
sounds terrible what if you were going
through something and somebody just cut
you off like try to take a second and be
like yo you need to work on this this
and that the one thing i do say is every
single person in our group does not have
an ego so like really if no if you wanna
oh my god if one of us is like nah [ __ ]
you you check each other you're out of
the group you're not in the group yeah
yeah yeah you can't be in the group
there's no that's why it works it is
kind of difficult they always say you
can't mix you know your friendships with
work or family with work you guys
because you all work on the podcast
together yeah does it ever get
you know sometimes too honest or do you
guys ever fight or do you hold it oh
yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah crying fights
yeah yeah off camera how do you resolve
that i grew up in arizona with my guy
friends and we we were all like kind of
fighters so we would fight each other
like legit fist fight each other here we
go uh we did like muay thai so we just
like kind of beat the [ __ ] out of each
other doing that
so i always knew that was boys or fights
you know like that's it i knew girls
kind of hold a little bit more in their
heart we go for more um mind games well
no that's not true sofia you used to
physically fight because i couldn't beat
you and then i would take her down with
my words yeah that's the thing so she
would tell me something that would break
me inside and then you would just sit on
me it was very rude i still can so yeah
it's nice that's the only way we but
yeah you were saying sorry no no i just
i love this dynamic though i know i feel
like you guys will be the type of person
like all right the rings are coming off
i don't know we take the hoops off we
really
think my parents used to say if you're
going to fight you got to head outside
so when we were younger we would
actually be like thrown outside well
it's funny too because my dad did raise
his like boys so he'd put us on the lawn
and be like all right go no kicking here
no pulling that guy
dude i love the fact that your dad's
like a box office all right sweetheart i
just came back from the premiere of
one of another billion dollar companies
fight it out no george i don't think you
understand our morning routine with sly
for six years yeah every single morning
before school he'd wake us about five
thirty sly
i don't know people are like why don't
you call them dad i just think it's
weird
what is that sylvester sly is his name
short short first semester sly yeah
all right yeah it's live
we'll circle back to that one oh look a
gift
so he would wake us up at 5 30 every
single day and he would make us
uh swing a golf club clean and jerk 10
times clean and jerk deadlifts yeah
push-up sit-ups throw shot put all
before school then sprints and also you
guys gotta check your vocabulary before
you start to go it's uh what's the
circle jerk what's the what's up yeah
it's a cleaning jerk when you please
clean and jerk
okay it's a normal it's not about it's
like a squat we call it it's not a
normal thing but we had like six packs
but it was funny because we know when
you said your mom used to tell you stop
talking like stop getting yourself into
trouble like calm down our dad used to
say and this is what my mom actually got
pissed off at with him he would train us
how to throw a punch so what he said was
have someone say it to you one more time
knock him out so we grew up knowing how
to fight so we can box and so what we
would not we never did it but we were
trained in case someone would throw
hands or say something mean to us he
encouraged us did your dad ever give you
like like just like
you get the biggest knocks you know does
he ever just kind of give did you ever
hear one of those lies from the movie
while he's like talking to you oh oh
this is the worst we played every sport
as well and it was so we would never
invite him to the games because you know
he just make it about him it's just who
he is he loves the attention so he'd sit
in the stands i'm playing volleyball or
you'd be screaming
i heard the tiger no there's a tiger and
he's like
what else would he say
i was like
it's like oh no we know his quote is so
embarrassing you guys were playing
football were you guys wearing like
volleyball oh volleyball
our basketball whatever it was and he's
just screaming like all right the time
no he's watching you get hit get back up
ten times yeah he he doesn't he doesn't
care he taught us what hooky was if i
got a c on a test he said you did better
than me i got enough what were we
talking about before you were talking
about how you went to euphoria for high
school
oh god i wish we went to the strictest
strictest high school no we were getting
back to you guys fight on set as much as
you like your brothers do normally yeah
yeah also we get along very very well
we're all very much the same but if we
do get into it we we always debrief yeah
that sounds really weird but yeah three
men four or five men will be in a room
and we'll just sit there and just talk
yeah sometimes we'll bring like personal
things in there and talk about it like
yo you need to stop doing this and this
right right we'll talk about it is there
anything off limits with you guys
because i know all of you uh vlog your
daily lives and i also have to know your
daily routines look if i were to vlog
our daily life it would be the most
boring episode of anything ever it's
like me making oatmeal and going to the
gym that's basically all i do
but is there anything that you guys are
shooting that you're like no off limits
you can't show that yeah a lot a lot
there's a lot of stuff that because we
have a lot of projects we're working on
yeah so all of us have like we have what
we're putting out into the world and
then we have our our personal projects
that we're all building
and
hey don't record this because it'll
it'll okay release it yeah especially
with logan logan's like the type of dude
that you have to like
i don't because i know exactly what to
do like i know what's no-nos and not but
like for example if other people are
like shooting yeah um
you have to like watch it yeah make sure
that there's nothing like totally yeah
and with our podcasts and stuff we have
like
a lot of people on like a uh like a
group chat yeah reviewing not for like
anything bad just kind of like no i
think it would be better if we do this
or yeah do this no i don't know like a
lot of people a lot of brands and when
you're exposing yourself that much on
camera i mean you're
so many platforms that you're you have
so many youtube channels you have your
instagram you have the podcast
is there any part of yourself that you
want to keep to yourself and not share
with the public yeah my relationship but
any any part of your personality though
or something like
like memories or stories that you're
like this is just yes
great question actually i've never had
anybody ask me that and so it took me a
second to like what is something that i
got yeah my mom always says you know you
don't always have to show all of your
cards so we'll do this podcast and we
often cut things over like you know
people actually don't need to know
everything yeah
so is there something for you yes so
the past two years of my life has
probably been the most
mental growth i've ever had
uh and a lot of it had to do with
spiritual like i want to dive into this
yeah um
and i was sit i was driving two and a
half hours a week
uh
like i would find a spot where i could
go because obviously i feel like you
guys kind of see through my vlogs i'm
always traveling right so i had to like
figure out a time where i could drive
three hours to this very very wealthy
man's house like probably the richest
man i've ever met in my life
and he's very spiritual too he believes
in jesus the way i do he was teaching me
his
his route but what i loved is that he
was so successful
so successful and so humble and so calm
and so meek didn't let anything anger
him he had a lot of peace in his heart
and i'm not trying to chase
anything that's materialistic i want
peace in my heart like i want to do what
i love and be happy yeah so i sat with
them and i said there's a part of me
that's selfish i want to be rich i
really want to be rich but i want to be
rich because i know i could do good
things
i go how can i be rich
and he turned to me and he says give
and i said what do you mean he goes
there's only one place in the bible that
says god test you could test god it's
only one place and he says if you give
ten percent of what you get in your life
to god and that's just giving it to
other people helping people out
and uh so i told that to my mom and my
mom said don't let your right hand know
what your left hand does
and i go what does that mean and she
goes if you're gonna go and help
somebody
in any certain way relationship business
financially
the term don't let this hand know what
this hand is is because it's such a
human thing to do we give
and then to show it off we'll go to our
girlfriend yeah go i i just gave this to
somebody yeah we're like oh i wanted
this right so she goes
watch what god will do to you and with
you
if you just keep that between you and
that person so now when i do things i
say hey this isn't from me this is from
god he put it in my heart so don't thank
me don't talk about it move on so that's
one thing i never ever ever do is i
never do donations online i never i
publicize that i'm helping meeting
someone or donating this i know because
a lot of people have that habit of
thinking that that's going to make them
look like a better person well i think
they're trying to uh put like
positive stuff out but i think i could
do that just by my actions right just
being who i am and people could be like
oh i bet he does that or whatever but
yeah that kind of trickled down into my
next rule and it's like if i do anything
for anybody else i also won't record it
because before i used to record it
because the content stuff yeah but i
can't let my
like i can't blur both my business and
my personal
so like how authentic is it if i gave
you a gift
like we're in a relationship right and i
give you something for an anniversary
and there's cameras around like at what
point are you it takes yeah for me 100
right right so that's one thing that we
don't do we don't do gifts between
friends like on camera yeah right so i
try to keep my my life personal but i do
i am a very much an open book yeah i
think it's because i can't lie like i
really can't lie okay that's great i
mean that's a like
thing yeah like i get so uncomfortable i
feel like also i have no reason a lot
i'm very proud of him right yeah so if
you have to put me in a situation where
i have to lie there's something fun
going on i got it right i totally agree
oh my god your girlfriend must feel so
good about that yeah bro that's a great
way to be she's all right but also she's
a baddie bro like she's a bad person so
like she's confident too but here i'll
show you a picture i don't know
she's my background just so this is i
feel like you guys oh [ __ ] yeah
beautiful she's she's stunning
she's beautiful but what happens is like
she's we we make we roast each other all
the time yeah oh yeah so we're at an
event literally this week and reid was
right dude i can't believe how
aggressive women are and they do not
give a [ __ ] about my girlfriend um oh
yeah yeah we gotta rap here to my face
grabbing me like holding my girlfriend's
hand wow we will look at me he's like i
can't believe it and so like i love that
you notice it and you actually go like
that's kind of [ __ ] oh i'll take steps
back and i'll make jokes okay we're done
taking applications for threesomes like
i'll just like talk i'll like push them
back and [ __ ] and like we'll make jokes
any other relationship that i had yeah
bro i would be sweating right if a girl
came up to me and was hitting on me that
openly from my girlfriend i'm like oh
we're fighting
right right right this is my
relationship with my girlfriend
literally she'd be like super confident
blah blah blah
the girl walk away and she'd be like
[ __ ] again and i go but her ass
though i go she could do it because of
her ass she goes no her face was like a
you know like yeah she has to be so like
yo but she's so confident in herself
that she knows that nothing would happen
oh yeah i'll make jokes i'll be like
fine you can [ __ ] that guy and i'll
point to like a really tall good looking
guy you have to like be light-hearted
about it because this [ __ ] happens all
the time but do you think it's also
because she trusts you i'm talking about
[ __ ] because i want guys to try this
[ __ ] out like yeah yeah yeah so for my
relationship especially in the industry
that i'm in it got really hard to be in
a monogamous relationship right so
[ __ ] hard was that because that
people around you
i think at any point if a guy is getting
women thrown at him i mean any type of
way yeah guys are dogs bro like they'll
do whatever but like even a good man
with a good heart you put him in a bad
situation he can make slip up yeah every
man can make a mistake so what i do is i
take myself out of situations where i
can make a mistake yeah just because why
the [ __ ] am i saying i don't want to put
myself in a bad situation so uh
i stopped watching porn first of all
like i got rid of that because i
realized at a young age i was like yo
like i'm watching porn and i'm teaching
myself that like i'm done with this girl
when i want to put her in the position
that i want to put her in and then i
move on to the next
girl and then yeah so my body's like yo
i can't be satisfied with one girl yeah
so like i nipped that
way and that actually seriously helped
me at times but then i hit impulsive and
the stand-up thing and i've never i've
always been the guy that's like yo like
ha ha make you laugh and then the girls
are like oh he's kind of funny like yeah
but then when like he got to the point
where in in logan put me on a show and
that has changed me overnight like it
was weird it went from oh hey dude i
like your videos to people stopping me
in the street and yeah talking to me for
30 minutes about what i said like
pivoted their points wow so
now these girls that i come off stages
are very very aggressive with it so yeah
i feel like they know you at this point
because they watch you they know where
you go who you are so mind you went from
kid that got kicked out of school made
fun of blah blah blah and then now this
is like a whole different chapter in my
life that i'm like yo this is sick and
there was a part of me there's a part of
me is like oh like any human
should i be in a relationship right now
like i just got everything that i worked
for like you know like this like what if
and then now i'm starting thinking in my
head
in my head she's so young what happens
in five years she's done and like that
so like then i was like yo wait hold on
that can't be a good thought right this
girl's a ride or die she's perfect in
any way
so i came up to her and i told her i go
listen i'm having a problem with
monogamy it has nothing to do with me
not loving you
it's just i have to be open and honest
and any other guy who tell you that he
would be in my shoes and feel otherwise
is a liar
i don't want to lie to you so like how
how do we like how do i take this as
soon as i told her it was really weird
bro yeah as soon as i told her like yo
this is an issue
i don't know why i don't know if it was
like the guilt thing or like the fact
that these girls were doing it i wasn't
telling her but once it happened it
turned into the game where we'd make fun
of it or like we were talking about it
you know what it is i took a bad
situation and now it's one of my
favorite things about it honestly you
having that open dialogue and being
honest with her was almost like just
being honest with yourself you have to
or you start resenting the person you're
with because you're not 100 but it's
more about you and sometimes like you'll
project or i'll do this i'll project on
the relationship that i'm in but it
really it's something that i'm dealing
with you're right you are a very honest
and open person but if you are you trust
me it hurts it sucks yeah but think
about this i tell this to people all the
time if you go to the gym and you do the
stroke things right the jerker oh yeah
yeah yeah so you're on track and and
you're you're you're lifting weights
you're doing the squats
your legs are going to hurt right yeah
but that's growth
you have to tear some [ __ ] to have
growth right so sometimes you have to go
through the pain it's called growing
pains and people don't want to have this
with their spiritual side or their
relationship side yeah and i'm all about
growth so if it hurts or it sucks or
it's annoying i don't give a [ __ ] let's
get it done now so i don't have to sleep
thinking about i have to do it the next
morning you have to because if you let
it simmer then it's never going to go
anywhere and then it's going to be
explosive because if imagine if you did
not bring that up to your girlfriend
and said like you weren't bringing up
the whole monogamy thing was a problem
that easily could have festered into
something else and then been way more
detrimental in the future and probably
not even about what it was in your first
year yeah i probably would have never
cheated but what how many more thought
so this is what i i've again reflected
about myself i'm more panic about
situations that don't exist than things
that are actually happening in my life
oh my god
[Applause]
i said this in the last podcast it might
sound a little cheesy but hear this out
this is something i just stumbled upon
uh the present the the now the present
is a gift from god
and the devil's gonna stop try to steal
that joy from you right so what is he
gonna do you have a podcast that's going
really well i don't know if you guys are
in relationships right now but say
say life is going really really well
yeah and you know it is yeah but you
catch yourself panicking and being
worried and being hard on yourself and
then start thinking like well if this
happens and i have to worry about this
this isn't that and my mom told me she
goes yo that's like somebody giving you
a gift and then immediately instead of
you cherishing that gift and playing
with that gift and using that gift
you're like oh my god what happens if
the gift breaks or blah blah blah it's
like yo like chill yeah yeah enjoy the
gift yeah and here's the worst part my
mom goes and if something bad happens
god forbid yeah why don't you just deal
with it then why are you gonna panic
before it happens right
and i really do feel this is why humans
don't know when they're gonna die i
really feel like it would [ __ ] them up
completely oh my god i didn't even think
of it like that that's
i need a moment but i need a moment
very well like you're so wise yeah also
you're really good at putting it into
the most simplistic way possible i feel
like a lot of people they don't know how
to put into words like what they're
trying to feel or say and you're able to
just articulate that
[Music]
ladies going to the pharmacy in person
is so 2021 you can get your birth
control online prescribed and delivered
for free with the pill club gain time
and peace at mine back with the pill
club their licensed medical team puts
your reproductive health first with
affordable birth control period care and
sexual wellness products all with an
online subscription life is stressful
enough luckily getting birth control and
sexual wellness products can be one less
thing you have to worry about with the
pill club you'll never
have to make an appointment with that
doctor again or wait in that stupidly
long line at the pharmacy with the pill
club it delivers your birth control
right to your door for free and discreet
packaging along with fun self-care gifts
and products if you need to renew your
birth control prescription want to
switch your birth control or maybe try
it for the first time the pill club
medical team has your back
get help finding the best option whether
it's the brand you know or not the pill
club carries over 120 fda approved
products and ships to all 50 states most
brands of birth control are free with
insurance or medicaid otherwise prices
start as low as seven dollars per month
without insurance want more their
licensed medical team is just a text
away to give you the best reproductive
health care advice right now when you go
to the pillclub.comwhack
the pill club is offering a 10 donation
to bedside org for every unwaxed
listener who becomes a patient your
donation will help low-income
individuals get access to birth control
through bedsider.org that's
thepildclub.com
unwax to get your first birth control
care package and donate to help more
women in need of affordable birth
control remember
thepillclub.com unwaxed you must use the
link to make a donation
i have a loaded question oh good
do you think uh she is the one
you do i think she's the one so i don't
believe in the one
oh what are your thoughts i don't
believe in uh i don't believe in like uh
soul mates i don't believe in that okay
i think this kid misconstrued women into
into thinking i know this sounds kind of
deep yeah but this kid [ __ ] them up
because when a girl or a boy growing up
feels like i'm waiting for my other half
they've already kind of lost because
you're not here to serve or to be
somebody else's sidekick or maybe
they're superhero whatever you are you
on this planet yeah right and god
created other people on this planet yeah
and they're just as amazing oh look at
that hello
some might say that's a little sign
but what i'm saying is so
if you okay i have my own relationship
with god how fair would it be if he's
like well you have to wait until the
right one comes your way the one i built
but you can see her you could see
growing old with her yes i and i mind
you i'll be super blessed if it was to
work out yeah but i told her in like a
year of dating i go i i know how great
god is that if me and you didn't work
out you would find somebody even better
and there was probably because you
needed growth in that direction yeah and
then i would find somebody here
something again that took off the what
the the pressure the weight so now we're
just here because we love each other and
we want to be here so so again these are
just thoughts so if i just sat there
like you should have won what's what's
the next question what if she's not the
one oh so again that's me battling the
future and i'm not god and who knows i
can get hit by a car tomorrow so why am
i going to sit here worrying about the
future so much when there's so much on
my plate right now to be grateful for
right she might not be the one but damn
it yeah right now she's the one and
she's amazing i feel like i'm in therapy
right now you are and i charge exactly i
love it
by the way i'm hitting all of you guys
with my rates too you're just so humble
and you don't have an ego and
being in la being in this world that
we're in it's very easy to get in your
own head and you are by the way i was
very cocky i was no but you didn't seem
it you seemed very humble and sweet they
said before you were yeah yeah yeah yeah
now you're from what we know no you're a
stand-up guy well i appreciate it it's
always a working progress i feel like
you're just waking up every day and
you're just trying to take some stuff
apart i my thing that i'm working on now
is like anger like i just don't want to
get angry at little things yeah my
favorite quote that somebody told me is
like if you're not gonna remember it in
five years don't give it five minutes oh
yeah i write that somewhere i was like
[ __ ] yeah dude cuz there's so many
things have you guys ever like this is
what i love have you ever gotten mad at
something so much you're like brother
[ __ ]
and you like and you look back at how
you behaved at that and you're like
i think it happened last night oh yeah i
popped off
over a text
and then two minutes later i'm like what
that wasn't even that bad have you ever
felt like you're crazy like you're like
oh i'm psyched oh no i knew i was crazy
the other day when i was having a
conversation with my boyfriend and i was
like i know what i'm saying right now is
making me look crazy which is pissing me
off and not made me sound crazy and i'm
not
all the crazy and i was like wait i know
what i'm saying makes me sound crazy but
i'm not a crazy person but i guess if
i'm saying i'm not crazy though then
anybody even matters
you said you sounded crazy i was like i
was like i was [ __ ] on a tangent can
i is it too deep what were you guys
arguing about was it like something big
or small no it was something like we had
to hear from each other in a few hours
oh yeah no no i'll answer that for him
yeah that's crazy no you said you're
ready
my location says you're at ralph so
i know i sound crazy right now i know i
know but she pulls out her [ __ ] her
knife the necklace that her dad gave her
i don't want to have to do this you know
what jordan i was i was hoping when you
come on the podcast that you were gonna
roast at least one of us and i'm really
happy i'm oh no i i got you guys i'll do
it i love it but thank you
so much for coming on the stream i
appreciate thank you guys for reaching
out yeah i mean i'm sure people already
know where to find you but please wait
for youtube your instagram yeah yeah uh
george django follow me uh google me uh
watch my movie no escape
and uh
and yeah man just have fun
yeah have fun take what i say with the
great summer
take no you gave some solid yeah you did
but also not if i don't want anybody to
listen to this be like do this guy spit
i'm not tony robinson
i'm just saying how honestly you've
already showed me that you live like 100
different lives and you're only 29. how
do you know you're not gonna be the next
tony robbins dude at this point at this
point you don't know i feel like you're
going to come out with some tapes i
think you're going to come out on some
stage thing and you're going to be no i
don't want that that is something i
actually really want to do in my future
no i see i can i can get you on speed
dial as my personal therapist no i got
you i'll actually write book about what
i need to do with you
millions of people
do you twitch and freak out at your
boyfriend do you stab your sister with a
switchblade your father gave you
chapter four
when she says she's not crazy when the
nun says lunchtime
striker with the right hook i am the
tiger god
and we're signing off thank you guys so
much for watching this week's episode of
the unwaxed box and we will see you next
tuesday bye
[Music]
you